When you were playing
with the label element,
did you notice how the label
appeared next to the input?
This is not an accident.
It makes it easier to see the label.
Please remember, portrait and landscape
view have different form factors.
In landscape view ports,
like this one, labels should
be next to the input elements.
In portrait view ports,
like this one, labels should
be above the input elements.
Few things to keep in mind.
If you are not careful, custom scroll
handlers may scroll input elements
to the top of the page hiding the label.
You should especially avoid placing
labels below the input elements
because you run the risk that they
may be covered by the virtual
keyboard, not good.
For example, here we make sure that
all the labels appear above the inputs
because, as you can see,
the virtual keyboard is coming up.